[Music]
hey kid a little young for a bartender
aren't you a little old for prom aren't
you
[Music]
everything in here why the map it's the
biggest treasure that's never been found
five billion easy but it's just a story
i beg to differ
[Music]
500 years ago
my family found the world's biggest
fortune
then was betrayed
people have been searching for it all in
vain
both you turn your keys clockwise at the
same time
thanks a lot he almost got me killed
clockwise sully oh it was 50 50 so i
made a guess clearly
but the voyage was not just about gold
or something much more valuable this
cross has a very tragic history so much
i'm blood sure he's just threatening to
kill me
don't get caught
you were just gonna leave me back there
somebody had to get the cross
[Music]
[Applause]
your brother believed that there was a
final piece
well you know my brother said
you have no idea who you partnered with
what else aren't you telling
me the victor
spoils
how are they going to get them out of
here
wow
[Music]
hey put them down boys
what is that thing on your face
puberty's right around the corner kid
you can grow your own
exclusively in movie theaters
is a concept about which we know
frighteningly little
it was the only way
but i never
meant for any of this to happen
[Music]
wonder
i knew someone later you'd show up
i made mistakes
and people were hurt i'm not here to
talk about westview
then what are you here for i need your
guess
help
what do you know about the multiverse
[Music]
i'm sorry steven
i hope you understand
the greatest threat
to our universe
[Music]
is you
things just got out of hand
as a private contractor
you're possessing a unique set of skills
[Music]
what's that
power you said it was clear i said the
front was clear
um
front back right wrong
anyway shall we
[Music]
so what we got something rather nasty
has been stolen
we have to stop that's getting on to the
open market
who's the buyer greg simmons the
billionaire arms dealer
oh a lot very serious faces up here in
there you can't catch this fish with
conventional lures i'm sorry the lure
being daddy francesco
the movie star rick simmons favorite
movie star and how do we get him
blackmail
who's to get
very good carry on
the world needs you for your greatest
role yet who are you i'm your new
manager there's a sensitive and awkward
situation between you and your
sister-in-law i actually love my
sister-in-law
just out of here you made that quite
evident when marimba rhythms start to
play
i'm ready
let's go to work when someone pinch me
please is that danny francesco what's
next for you i'm playing a mysterious
self-made billionaire you just described
me
shadow mate do whatever i do whatever i
do do
whoever greg was buying from was amongst
you last night
i can get inside the ukrainians
i hope you take them to dinner first
before you get inside of them
sexually
they're going to kill you now we'll
shoot them first then
tidy
what happens you recognize your awesome
fortune that is a sexy name cover's
blown we're burnt what do i do the movie
star's gonna melt
you stop danny francesco you stopped
so you weren't seen by anyone
yes
that's yes you weren't seen by anyone
yes or yes you were seen by someone yes
[Music]
july 20th
1969.
[Music]
in school you were taught that apollo 11
lost contact with the world for two
minutes
[Music]
not true
they found something on that day
that they kept him for 50 years
and now
it's too late to stop
in breaking news the governor has just
ordered the mass evacuation of the
entire west coast
moving to higher ground it's the only
possible chance of surviving
stay away my brothers and sisters
stay awake
this planet
has suffered five
extinctions this
is going to be the sixth
are we dead
you know we are just inside the moon
that might be the greatest sentence
anyone's ever said
[Music]
[Music]
uh do you need a doctor
i am a doctor
i should have died years ago
people all over the world have my
disease come here
to find a cure
we have to push the boundaries take the
risks
[Music]
if you're gonna run
do it now
then you were found on a container ship
that washed up off a long island faces
look ugly
when you're alone
what did you do to yourself doctor
i wish i knew
i went from dying to being more alive
than ever it worked
not exactly i have increased strength
and speed and some form of bad radar
what else can i do
[Music]
there are limits there has to be there's
something inside of you
he wants to hunt
and consume blood
we haven't had anything this good since
that thing in san francisco
hey dr mike you and i should stay in
touch
i'd do anything to save a life
but i don't know what i'm capable of
you save lives you don't take them
are you here to heal the world
or to destroy it
who the hell are you mad i
am just kidding it's dr michael morvious
at your service
if you listen carefully enough
the past whispers to you
we're here to see i was dumbledore
that would be my brother
the world as we know it is coming undone
renewal is pulling it apart with hate
if we're to defeat him you'll have to
trust me
[Music]
this is the team that's going to take
down the most dangerous wizard in over a
century
imagine zoologist this indispensable
assistant
wizard descended from a very old family
the school teacher
and
a muggle
dumbledore said i give you something
jacob
are you kidding me right now
who wouldn't like our chances
after save the world are we
things are not quite what they appear
swivel but delicately
i'm swiveling out yourself
[Music]
begin
today
what is this place
the room we require
[Music]
correct three points to hufflepuff
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
very dangerous it's very powerful i've
gotten wrong hands you know
mess you up where did you get it
the guy for christmas
[Music]
quick stretch little snack and here we
go
sonic i love that you want to help make
a difference
if you're being reckless don't worry
nobody's gonna get hurt
pretending to be batman blue justice
trademark pending you're still just a
kid
trust me there will come a moment when
your powers will be needed
but you don't choose that moment that
moment chooses you i just got goosebumps
wait a second did you steal that from
oprah
papa's got a brand new stash
since i've been gone i've discovered the
source of ultimate power
that sounds big
it's been on my vision board for years
hope i'm not too late
i'm sorry who are you
tails okay this is what we're gonna do
step one light taunting step two i have
no idea
[Music]
that wasn't too bad
today's forecast falls for a 100 chance
of adventure
[Music]
return to sender
face it you're never going to get my
power
do i look like i need your power
where
are my manners sonic meet knuckles
[Music]
uh
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
newlyweds mr and mrs simon
doyle you must meet archul puero my
congratulations madam mercy
but he's only the greatest detective
alive
i suspect you invited me for reasons
other than the fun
you had
we have the karnak all to ourselves a
chef and enough champagne to fill the
nile
when you have money no one is ever
really your friend
it's too late to change events it's time
to face the consequence
someone is dead
[Music]
the crime
is murder
were you aware of any grudges madame is
used to getting what she wants
never again
i don't feel safe
i don't feel safe with any of them
there are so many conflicting hates and
jealousies
oh i like this did you see or hear
anything
i did not trust her i still don't what
did you do last night you accused me of
murder
he accuses everyone of murder it is a
problem i admit
that murder was methodically planned
[Music]
someone else is dead
you lie in my face lock the doors
the murderer is here and we'll stay here
[Music]
[Music]
your instructor is one of the finest
pilots this program has ever produced
[Music]
his exploits
are legendary
what he has to teach you
may very well mean the difference
between life
and death
your reputation precedes you
have to admit i wasn't expecting an
invitation back
they're called orders maverick
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning aviators this is your
captain speaking today's exercise is dog
fighting two versus one he's gotta be
kidding
[Music]
smoke in the air
[Music]
on january 14th family movie night is
getting revamped only on prime video
for centuries no human has had the power
to become a monster
until now
but is this safe though let's find out
[Music]
is everything okay down here hey drac
what's up oops
what's going on i used van helsing's
transforming ring
you're human drag dad
oh no i have a total dad bod
um what is going on
[Music]
what's up
i'm baldy
[Music]
who are those guys it's me uncle griffin
you don't recognize me i've literally
never seen you before
there is a place deep in the amazon only
there can the transformations be
reversed time to go
stereo man
if we don't fix you guys dude you'll be
like this forever
being
coming january 14th only on prime video
please
heads up
[Music]
get out of here
[Music]
fear is a tool
when that light hits the sky
[Music]
it's not just a call
that's a warning
[Music]
i can take care of myself
if this continues it won't be long
before you've nothing left
i don't care what happens to me
it's only going to get worse for
oh you it easy sweetheart
hear everything they say
maybe we're not so different
who are you under there
inventions
what's black
and blue
and dead
all over
dick
i got you
[Music]
i'm sorry brother
sorry that i brought you into this i
just wanted things to be the way they
used to be
that's my brother will i could use some
help my wife needs to search me this is
real life how's that right you put your
life down on the line for this country
you leave your family your home how much
do you need 231.
how about
more
32 million and i need an extra minute i
came to you for a loan look have i ever
gotten you anything that i couldn't get
you out of it's time for you to do
something for your family
we're gonna do you for officer we're
just doing a transfer from the back i'll
let you in in 20 minutes uh if i could
just get it down real quick because i'm
on the clock promise not to rob the
place
seriously because that would be bad for
my job
my brother okay all right okay
let's go dude you are all gonna have the
greatest story to tell at dinner tonight
lock everything down
nothing gets out
[Music]
just gonna borrow it i got a cop shot i
gotta get him to the hospital i'm gonna
need you to help us why don't you help
us we're doing hostages now
we're not crashing into this ambulance
we got a brother cop on board do you
have empty experience come back to the
eyes you're a soldier yeah
we are trying to save you
you think you're so tough with that gun
no danny relax
i gotta get back to my wife and my son
does your wife know you're all banks
we're not the bad guys
we're just the guys trying to get home
we don't get to walk off into the sunset
danny everybody knows how dangerous you
are do you
you get your heroes out of here now
i'm gonna get you back home little
brother i'm gonna get everybody home
[Music]
this isn't funny amber would you like to
play a game tara
[Laughter]
doors unlocked
all doors locked
doors unlocked
hello
it's happening
three attacks so far do you have a gun
i'm sydney prescott of course i have a
gun
something about this one just feels
different
samantha
i'm i know who you are
i've been through this
a lot
this is your life now which means that
whoever this is is going to keep coming
for you
[Music]
are you ready
for this
never oh
there's certain rules to surviving
the attacks were all on people related
to the original killers
whatever his link is to our past
it's pulled us all back here
and i won't sleep until he's in the
ground
hello
[Music]
it's an honor
[Music]
[Music]
crash at my place baby
[Music]
how did you get
how have you been
it's a long story
is this the room you grew up in uh it is
but uh my my dorm room is very adult
right no of course
hey are these your drawings what no no
good
i missed you too okay
so what are you doing here
i mean i i thought i'd
never see you again
want to get out of here
[Music]
i'm
grounded
bummer is spider-man grounded
um
i mean
[Music]
oh
flight recorders are on t minus five
four
three
[Applause]
we have not
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
he'd like to come and meet us
[Music]
to infinity
and
[Music]
say what i want 24 7 365.
i know it's a lot
but i don't got time to mess around
oh about that hustle am i right
this is gonna be the best year ever
and nothing's gonna get in my way
[Music]
breakfast is ready
[Music]
gonna be may
is everything okay
i'm a gross red monster
oh look at me stay back this happened
already what did you say
our ancestors had a mystical connection
with red pandas are you kidding me this
little quirk runs in our family
you're so cute sick i've always wanted a
tail i'm a freak we love you mae you're
our girl
whoa you're you
any strong emotion
will release the panda abby hit me
[Music]
do you know how dangerous this is you'll
get whipped up into a frenzy and panda
all over
my whole life i've been perfect little
maymay
but maybe i like this new me
you led me straight to the lost city now
prepare to die there were just hundreds
of snakes in this temple just waiting
for us to show up what why aren't they
biting that guy this is ridiculous
delete
delete
listen loretta we need you to promote
your new book on the lost city you can't
spend your life in the bathtub drinking
chardonnay with eyes
ladies and gentlemen the world's sexiest
cover model
mcmahon
you do know you're not dash right dash
is a character i made up that's oh my
god
oh crap
sage i enjoyed your book about the lost
city and i believe you're the one who
can help me find its treasure
i have to respectfully decline i'm
afraid i must insist
unchain me that's your seat belt
oh no
loretta sage is missing i'm gonna rescue
her i just want her to think of me as
more than a cover mop that's not living
dangerously
alan what are you doing here we're here
to save you i'm certified cpr i'm
certified crossfit
i have snacks after them
this is like your book we're on the love
more and dash adventure right now i'm
gonna help you out a little bit let's go
what are you doing don't do that get out
of there this is not a romance novel
jungles eat people like us what is that
get it off
i can feel them suckers
feels like there's more holy mother of
god ah they're just sucking on my butt
like a big old jamba juice
we're so close i could actually find the
lost city
if i don't get to this island my friend
and her cover model are going to die i
am driving oh oh oh
oh
oh
the red sage getting you out of here why
are you so awesome my dad was a weather
man
hey oh she doesn't need saving in there
uh what are you doing in there
[Music]
the old wars
cold war war on terror
he knew who we were fighting
but now the enemy is invisible
they can destabilize entire countries
from simple reach of their keyboard
[Music]
officially i can't put you on this
but if you were to go out on your own
i would need some help
i'm guessing this isn't a social pool
i'm putting together a team and you're
the best in the world of what you do
i thought this was done i'll be back for
dinner tomorrow
[Music]
hands put your gun down please five four
three two one pull the trigger or you
can listen
we all work for different intelligence
agencies
american
british
german colombian chinese
but now we have a common enemy and if we
don't stop then
let's start world war iii
so we need to join forces
you have cameras in your jewelry comes
in your earrings
this is like half the cia's most wanted
you bump i grab
but thanks for the tip
i have two children
i am a normal person i cannot do this
anymore that guys are out there right
now you go home
you bring them with you
are you under control are you
no
we put ourselves in danger
so others aren't
[Music]
[Music]
355.
[Music]
tell me something
[Music]
you can go
anywhere you want right
any timeline
and the universe
[Music]
why do you want to stay
and fight to save this one
you change the
future you change the path
are you in
in five weeks a hundred thousand british
forces will strike sicily southern shore
unfortunately the nazis know of our
intentions
so we're going to play a humiliating
trick on hitler
[Applause]
we have to convince germany that our
target is greece the plan begins in
spain where the corpse will wash up on
shore bearing classified letters
a corpse carrying fake documents
given the fascist network there we could
quite literally float the documents
right into enemy hands
prime minister that's too big a risk the
fate of the world is at stake the plan
is highly implausible
so when can it be ready
well let's say we start with the easy
part and find ourselves a corpse
the thing is to scrutinize every detail
of our fallen man
where are his legs
he must be as real as your eye he would
carry a letter from his wife professing
her deep love for her very good
and he would carry her photograph my
contribution to the mission for a seat
at the table
although
what if the autopsy reveals he didn't
die of drowning
or if the briefcase is returned to us
without the germans seeing its contents
charles why on earth do you keep poking
holes in our plan i'm preemptively
poking
success depends
on guiding the papers into hitler's
hands
the nightmare marching this way is only
too real in the spanish lately the
germans anywhere near our briefcase we
are in the dark
if the enemy is waiting for us on those
beaches
history herself will avert our eyes from
the slaughter
i may vomit
i may vomit with you
in stories of war there is that which is
seen and that which is hidden
[Music]
in god's name fleming wasn't writing
spy story
in the hidden war the truth
is protected by a bodyguard of lies
its soldiers unseen
pray it's heroes and son
this
is our war
[Music]
wake up buddy it is one o'clock
maybe i should let him sleep
okay
[Music]
go for a walk
i have an owner and he's superman let me
just turn that out
i should call me iron man
no
my dog's the best but he's not the
greatest with other animals what is new
with you fellow normal dog i bit the
fedex guy the other day who was he
working for general zod the legion of
doom
[Music]
fedex of course the federation of x's
not to be trusted
what is taking my owner so long
well well well
if it isn't the justice league
superman
what's going on
you're super strong i should be a lot
more dead right now right
my best friend is in danger and you have
to help me well we're just a bunch of
shelter pets
but they're stronger than you think the
mighty oil
i didn't see anything show on wheels
where the heck am i indestruct dog
great i'm the only one who didn't get
any superpower
when one has an abundance of power
they have a certain duty to use that
power to
[Music]
sorry you were saying something
how much did you have to drink i had two
toilet bowls and a bidet bidet too just
which is crazy i didn't even know that
was the thing but it's like a dog water
fountain
oh out of the way cat child
hey deploy k9g what is a
excellent shielding that seemed
incredibly painful
anybody want to switch powers
now
behold
he's here
he's here
father is here the kingman lady the king
your fake is set and you cannot escape
it
i've missed you my son
one day this kingdom will be yours
thank you father
my king
father
remember
foreign
[Music]
i won't kill you
why would he stir away to such a hellish
place
to find what was stolen from me
and what is that
the kingdom
you must choose between kindness for
your kill
or hate for your enemies
your strength breaks man's bones
[Applause]
i have the calling to break their minds
and night by night we will carry out my
pledge of
vengeance will save you
mother save your mother
hmm
hey you get over here
oh i know what it is you're afraid
because i'm the big bad wolf
the villain of every story
and this is the crew mr tarantula mr
shark mr piranha mr snake everyone copy
copy copy
we're the bad guys it's crime time baby
we need a distraction do i get to
improvise fine please be subtle
i'm having a baby
is there a doctor or perhaps several
security guards that could leave that
post and help me
we were never given a chance to be
anything more than criminals but these
are the cars we've been dealt so we
might as well play him
here let me help you
are you okay ma'am thank you dear you're
such a good boy wait what
[Music]
oh good yeah yeah
you ever wonder what it'd be like if the
world wasn't scared of us never gonna
happen guys we're gonna go good
did you get hit on the head you villains
have an image problem you need a
makeover
so
well there goes our street cred
i'm tired of being an outcast maybe i
don't want to be a what a bad guy you
can't have to choose between your
friends or the good life they're the
only friends i've ever had you have a
chance to write your own story what have
you got to lose i don't know my dignity
yeah well that ship is already sailed so
you're a tough guy
that is an animal testing that with
helpless guinea pigs i'll rescue them
you've never volunteered for anything
oh
come on snake open up relax these doors
are complicated
are you kidding me we're supposed to
save them not eat them well i'd say
they've gone to a better place
i'm a bad
[Music]
guy i'll be home in the morning where
are you going i'm staying over at
susie's tonight
what's new
the flyer
the papers call him the grabber i wish
one combat you don't actually believe
that story do you because he can't hear
you and he doesn't really take kids that
say
oh
you goof beautiful isn't that just
peachy cute you need some help you see
that
would you hand me my hat
yes sir
i
am a part-time magician
are those type of ones in there
would you like to see a magic trick
i have an announcement to make one of
our students finney blake was abducted
what if i could help the police find
benny
[Applause]
[Music]
does it work
not since i was a kid
i'll scream i'll scratch your face
this face
daddy i had a dream about it what
happened in your dream he was taken by a
man with black balloons yes we never
release those details
huh don't hang up
who are you
you're getting out of here
please please let the dreams be real see
the wall in front of you i tore long
cable loose from down there
there's a combination lock on the inside
of the storm door what's the combination
i carved it in the wall
the tree the door the gate i've never
seen it before except in my dreams you
don't have much time
you're gonna use a weapon you raise the
phone step back and swing
look what you made me do
please hurry you remember what i told
you
there's someday i should stand up for
myself someday it's today fans
it's time for us to move out and make
our mark on the world
awesome
oh no
those ding-dongs went back to the lost
world oh and i thought i made bad
choices
the lost world
the world's most dangerous place
wait a minute can you repeat that
i had a marshmallow in my ear oh [ __ ]
crying out now
what brings you to here
we came here to live a life of adventure
like you
i'm starting to question our judgment
this is the perfect time to do it
it's time to get
back wild [ __ ] look like a superhero
i wouldn't use the term superhero
i mean i wouldn't stop you from using it
i love family
reunions expired sir oh come on man you
know how many times i've been in and out
of this gate with that excuse me what's
the odds on isis it's about the vehicle
sir you want me to step off the vehicle
i'll have him he's with ranger battalion
ranger battalion
i've been busting my ass to get my mind
and my body back into a good place i
need to get back in the game sir you
want to get back in the game prove it
sergeant rodriguez was a legend family
funeral sunday outside of nogales they
want his dog at the funeral you do this
and you're back in the game
she won't work with anyone one minute
she's good the next minute she's sending
three guys to the er what's up dawg and
you're gonna go on a little road trip
easy what are y'all so scared smell it
out [ __ ]
what is your deal man maybe just take
crazy down one notch
[Music]
right no no no no
no you're just a demon you're just a
demon
whatever happened to you dogs you used
to be eleven
[Music]
you're so good how'd you make her get
out of your hand i just talked to her
see she's just a noodle she just knew so
good
[Music]
you don't do anything else psychotic on
this trip maybe we can have some fun is
that a deal
lulu is that you good girl you give hugs
now really lulu gets the best of you've
never had a lulu
no we don't we don't we don't exactly
hug
so you're telling me that nuke was just
as messed up as luba i had to work him
every day for six months when he stopped
struggling that's when i realized maybe
i could stop struggling
it's too it's just lightning right
look at that
she's never slept in a nice bed before
there ain't no shame in wanting a big
comfy mattress i was hoping you might
have a room for me and my little girl is
that a purple heart was she wounded um
yes she she was thank you for your
service
we've never seen this dog exhibit any
aggressive behavior before never she
loves people
[Music]
oh my god i can i can see
you're definitely not the girl i thought
i'd be in the tub with but
i'll take what i can get at this point i
guess
[Music]
i'm supposed to meet a man here
to take me to the compound
came from the west right
here is getting pretty bad out that way
now
folks turning on each other
so why the compound
he's a strange place to be heading
once in a lifetime opportunity
what is it
come here look at this
that's gold
we just bought a pile of gold
one of us will have to get the excavator
to get it out
i think i'll stay with the gold
you gotta watch your water
stay out of the sun
ain't no joke out here
how much longer going
so you're here on your own
you need to leave
i think they're hiding something gotta
get rid of her
i found it
it's mine
[Music]
[Music]
you've been all over the world
you could have a shop anywhere you like
and yet you're here
it doesn't terribly much matter where i
am
i have my shears
what else does a man need besides the
shears
this isn't art
this is a craft
you cannot make something good
until you understand the customer
do we let all of our customers keep
black boxes in back
if we only allowed angels to be
customers soon we have no customers at
all
he says i don't want any trouble
i need you to listen carefully
there are a thousand blue boys out there
hunting for this and if they find it i
start shooting you follow making matters
worse there are a thousand racket boys
hunting for it too and if they find it
they start shooting you follow you don't
want to be involved in whatever it is
you do
you know exactly what it is that we do
well
full house tonight huh
have you ever heard of the outfit the
outfit is a network of every big time
crew from santa monica to coney island
and tonight they sent us a message
they're hiding something my friend
[Music]
i'm gonna need that take pal right now
why don't you try and take it gentlemen
it's gonna be a long night
sell him up what
i can't
sew him up
you need to tell me what really happened
in here tonight
now
you got five seconds to tell me what
happened open the trunk what open the
trunk and grab his arms or i'm hiding
two bodies five a number of things about
me that you don't know
four who's the tape for instance three
i'm telling you the truth
you want to survive the night
you look up dead in the eyes and you
pretend you're one of them
[Music]
she's out
[Applause]
[Music]
the marry me concert is something you
will not want to miss
in 36 hours superstar kat valdez and
grammy winning bastian will perform
their new song marry me and exchange
files in front of a streaming audience
of 20 million people [ __ ] tonight
i'll be the one in the veil charlie this
is once in a lifetime i've got my
daughter tonight good i've got three
tickets for tonight bring her dad you
haven't had any fun since mom left just
say yes
what am i doing here okay let's go we
only have five minutes
what's everybody looking at nothing give
me your phone
kat valdez husband-to-be bastion caught
cheating with her assistant
we love you cat hold this i'm told that
uh 20 million people are supposed to
watch as we take our vows they say if
you want something different you have to
do something different
why not
yes
[Music]
i'll marry you
you
go go go
do you
some guy
take cat to be a lawfully wedded wife
okay
that was crazy kat valdez left the guy
from the concert then also married her
uber driver it's an insane situation i
say we offer five thousand dollars and
let it all blow over or i could stay
married to him
i started something last night and if i
don't finish it i'll look crazy we gotta
get out in front of this hi
it's three months i don't even know her
we both did this so whether we like it
or not we're in this together we have to
embrace the spontaneity of the moment i
don't want to be the punchline
what do i do just stand and smile
this is the most unbelievable thing that
could ever happen in life
right now 237 000 people are like he
looks like he's a math club i am in a
math club
i don't know hanging with you guys today
i don't know it made me feel kind of
normal come with me to the fall
semi-formally are you asking me to the
school dance well i could leave a note
in your locker
[Music]
call me if you're lonely
hello
[Music]
are you afraid she'll fall back and love
bastion and help you
[Music]
i'd be afraid of that too we don't need
to pretend i don't fit
[Music]
this is smart
i think we left smart six weeks ago i
was on my way to you
who do you think you are a man some fan
no i'm not a fan just well i mean i am
now
[Music]
where am i going to a lavish and
glimmering hell
it always had the tails of a sigh
and stuff of dreams
[Music]
you you're something they can never be
an individual
this place is so beautiful
[Music]
[Applause]
creature in the water you should not be
swimming in there
she called me
she's certainly not of this world nor am
i
the creature will be killed placing the
life force into our hands this is murder
she is your pet she's all but human
the mermaid must escape the king
we're the only ones who can stop
[Music]
do you him in coincidence
[Applause]
[Music]
years ago
before you were born
i met a man
and now i've come into the possession of
a villa in the south of france what
three two one
[Music]
better be warned
the british are coming
[Music]
and with that i will say good night and
leave you to discuss my mysterious past
[Music]
[Music]
huh
[Music]